good morning Hank it's Tuesday so Bill
Gates is encouraging people to make
videos about what it means to be human
there's actually a contest you can win
money and stuff link in the doobly-doo
but as it happens over the last three
years I've been thinking a lot about
this question because I've been trying
to write a novel about what it means to
be human and how we define personhood
and why those definitions matter I've
also been writing a lot about tortoises
but that's less directly relevant here
all right so first off I find all the
like biological definitions of
humaneness completely uninteresting
because we all kind of just know that
there's something to personhood other
than just all being members of the same
species right like we know this partly
because most of us believe that humans
have a seemingly unique consciousness or
soul or whatever but we also know that
personhood is more than just a species
category because we can constantly see
people denying other people's humanity
even though we're all members of the
same species this happens on a macro
level when governments for instance
refused to acknowledge the very
existence of certain ethnic minorities
and it happens on a micro level every
time ID humanize someone by imagining
them as less complex than myself like
it's easy for me to understand that I
contain multitudes but rather than
understanding that of other people too
often I imagine them as merely sick or
merely poor or merely them to some us
that includes me take for me at least
the deeper I dig the harder it becomes
to understand what makes people people
for instance I often hear that what
makes us human is that we can share
stories across generations and I do
absolutely believe in the power of
narrative but there are many people who
can't tell or hear stories like people
with certain intellectual disabilities
for instance and yet they are still
people or like we often associate
reading and writing with humanists but
there are many people who can't read or
write and often they're marginalize
people the people whose humanity most
needs to be acknowledged the same goes
for many definitions of humaneness they
often exclude the poorest or the sickest
or the most oppressed and those narrow
definitions of humaneness can be very
dangerous like one dramatic example is
that for many centuries Europeans and
white Americans denied the essential
humanity of black people as a
justification for chattel slavery but
that's not just a problem of history
like to be treated as a full human in
the world today you may need not just a
human body and a human spirit but also
an ID card attesting to a particular
citizenship and wealth and race and sex
and class and many other things can all
factor in to how human the world
treats you so what can we say
inclusively of humans well we tend to be
capable of empathy and collaboration and
hope but in these respects I don't think
we're unique among animals it seems to
me that to get even remotely universal
and yet specific we have to be very
weirdly careful with our wording like
when able to access and comprehend the
teachings of our ancestors we tend to
value them here's what I really believe
Hank I believe that we confer personhood
upon each other through empathy and
compassion and Trust like stuck inside
the prison of my own consciousness I
have no way of independently verifying
that other people even are really human
like it's possible that everyone else is
just a super-realistic humanoid robot
and I am the only actual feeling human
on earth but I choose not to believe
that I believe that when we acknowledge
each other's consciousness and
complexity we lead better lives and feel
less alone in our grief and in our joy
basically I believe that we're human
because we believe in each other's
humaneness and because we can listen and
we can work together to alleviate each
other's suffering and in that sense I
guess being human is both something that
we are and something that we must always
aspire to be and of course I might be
wrong I often am that's quite human as
well I think so Hank nerdfighters I'm
very interested in knowing what you
think it means to be human let's
continue the conversation in comments or
via the link below Hank I will see you
on Friday